true or false tom brady uh story is the
most important and most annoying thing
in the nfl right now true or false
i would say true that's exactly the
that's the best way to to phrase it i'm
annoyed with it i actually had a moment
earlier in this week that i looked at
the clock and i looked at the calendar i
was like wait we're not gonna get an
answer to this for another two weeks but
there is an element of you know when you
get to these little pockets in the
sports calendar before march madness
before the nba playoffs the stanley cup
playoffs in baseball where there's not a
lot going on right in the late february
early march range
it's nice to have something to talk
about in the sports world so i
appreciate that but yes it is also very
annoying because we're talking ad
nauseum and guess what
i still think he's going to be
going back to the patriots and we're
going to be like what were we talking
about for the last three weeks
well if he does i hope that it's not
until the latest possible moment because
i don't consider it annoying because i'm
a businessman i'm trying to do business
and my business entails covering the nfl
and it is an important story and it is a
story in which there is a ton of
interest because i can see in real time
what people are reading and they lap up
the tom brady stories they want to know
what's going on with tom brady what
that's interesting so you're so you're
saying people are clicking on tom brady
stories
yes
oh yeah listen i've i've arrested mike
i've been down this road i i've there's
no case to rest i rest my case i'm in
the business of covering the nfl the
biggest story in the nfl right now is
tom brady so you shut up sir
this is how it goes this is how it goes
when you have a story that gets the
clicks that people want to read this is
it the stories start getting you know
coming out of thin air people say this
people say that we then have a day worth
of content it ha it's how it works mike
how can you not see it right half of
this stuff is just like plucked out of
air so that people can write about it
that's how this works well right welcome
how long have you been in this business
by the way you're in this business you
benefit from this pen national okay you
benefit from people talking about this
stuff and thinking about this stuff and
at least there's something ultimately at
the core here to discuss this isn't ron
jaworski saying colin kaepernick could
be the greatest quarterback of all time
and espn milking that into four days of
content because of all the people saying
how crazy juan ron jaworski is to say
that this is not something that's been
made up out of whole cloth there is
something there tom brady is careening
toward free agency we're trying to
figure out what's gonna happen he seems
to enjoy very much that he's in the
middle of this conversation so yeah
that's why we're here and that's why
we're on tv right now i don't understand
why you're biting the hand that's
feeding you i'm not biting the hand that
feeds me my job is to point out obvious
truths when you can't see them and i've
done that
oh i'd see the truth i say it's off it
is obvious that's why we don't need to
talk about it as much as you seem to
like to all right next up espn could
have interest in philip rivers for the
broadcast booth monday night football
true or false
rivers in the booth in 2020 would be
more interesting than rivers on the
field in 2020. oh that's close
i actually will say true because i'm
worried the philip rivers will not get a
starting job so being on the field in
2020 might be standing on the sideline
holding a clipboard so i'll go we
wouldn't do wouldn't do it yeah you
wouldn't do it all right no
franchise quarterbacks don't hold
clipboards baby they either play or they
walk away yeah so i yeah i mean i i
guess then i i still would like to see
philip rivers in the booth he's the
perfect guy for the job because he's got
an interesting accent you know he'll
never swear he's never sworn in his
entire life so you don't have to worry
about that and i think he has a good
perspective i mean he's been around
forever he's seen the game evolve he's
seen the game change i would love to see
philip rivers in the booth i i would
enjoy that very much
yeah i would too and i think it would be
more interesting than him on the field
unless interesting on the field is in
the jameis winston sort of way because
of all the interceptions that philip
rivers threw last year seven in a pair
of prime time consecutive games uh and
there's a thought that the colts are
going to go after and peter king made
the argument the other day they're not
going to spend big money on phillip
rivers or anyone else and you know my
first thought when the chargers
announced that philip rivers was hitting
the market is i don't think there's
anybody that's going to just back up the
truck and say here's 25 or 30 million
dollars because we've seen that there
has been a disintegration
in the skill set over the past year or
two all right true or false neither cam
newton nor christian mccaffrey will be
on the panthers next year true or false
i'm gonna go with false i think both
will be and i know we disagree on the
cam newton thing but i i think both will
be on on the panthers next year
the one to watch is mccaffrey because
mccaffrey is going to want a new
contract we talked about this yesterday
mccaffrey is going to want a new
contract i don't think he's going to
show up for anything until he gets the
new contract and depending upon what he
wants
and whether or not the panthers are
willing to pay and who knows what their
analytics people say about a running
back i mean this guy's a running back
and a receiver he had a thousand yards
rushing a thousand yards receiving one
of the most if not the most dangerous
weapons in all of football
if he wants a ridiculous amount of money
and the panthers say we can't justify it
there's somebody else out there that
makes them an offer they can't refuse
this could be a khalil mack situation
all over again so i i'm not ready to say
definitively but between newton and
mccaffrey i just think from a business
standpoint they got to keep one of them
so i won't say both so i'll say false
but i think one of them's going to be
gone big cat and and mike that's a great
point by you and i'll add to it the
business standpoint with christian
mccaffrey i have a couple friends who
live in the carolina area with kids and
he is
the number one guy like they
love love love christian mccaffrey he
sells the most jerseys probably now for
the franchise if you get rid of both of
them who is the face of the carolina
panthers you don't have one now so i
agree with you there that's one of those
costs of doing business you might not
want to give christian mccaffrey a ton
of money but you kind of have to because
you got to put people in the seats and
you got you got to get people to watch
and buy merchandise
yeah will greer would become the face of
the panthers if they get rid of cam
newton yeah they lost west virginia yeah
luke
they need to keep they need to keep one
or both of these guys and i think
mccaffrey's the one they need to find a
way to keep but they're gonna need to
find a way to pay him all right joe
burrow says he's going to attend the
2020 draft if there ultimately is one
but that's uh that crosses over into
things that we'd rather not talk about
because we're here for diversion and a
break from all the things that have
people freaked out right now true or
false there's no way he goes unless he
knows for sure he's the number one
overall pick i'm gonna say false i
actually think he would have gone if he
was top five pick top ten pick i i don't
i don't see this as as true i think he
will be the number one pick but if if
the uh implication here is that he has
been
completely guaranteed 100 that he is the
number one pick i'll push back on that
and that's the only reason he's going
i'll push back on that i think he would
go if he were a top five pick regardless
yeah i i agree with you because it's not
like he's gonna do an aaron rodgers
brady quinn's slide right if he's not
number one he's gonna be number two if
he's not number two he's gonna be number
three his floor is number five to the
dolphins and he ain't gonna last that
long and that's always the key
understanding your floor your ceiling
doesn't matter where's your floor and
the best agents do a very good job of
finding out what their guy's floor
really is and telling them this is your
floor because how many times have we
seen a guy plummet below where he
thought he was going to go all because
his agents didn't do a good enough job
figuring out which team was definitely
going to take him if he was there and i
guarantee you the dolphins will take joe
burrow at number five if he is there all
right one more true or false despite the
rumors washington will not pass on chase
young in order to take tuatanga viloa
true or false
i'm gonna say oh man i'm gonna say false
because i don't know i mean i i actually
do think that look taking a good hard
look at tua is not the worst idea for
the washington redskins you have to get
a franchise quarterback dwayne haskins
has shown a couple flashes but he's also
shown some things that haven't looked
good and it's a numbers game right like
if they have two and dwayne haskins and
they say look
yeah we we we just spent two first-round
picks on franchise franchise
quarterbacks quote unquote back-to-back
years
okay we might be you know that might be
crazy that might be looked at as insane
but you know what it also will be we'll
be making sure that we get a franchise
quarterback so i wouldn't i wouldn't put
it as a high probability but i also
wouldn't say that they're completely you
know
set on chase young and there's no chance
that they try to take tua
i agree with you uh completely but i
think a lot of this stuff about taking
tua is aimed at possibly trading down
and getting you have to know tua inside
and out in order to properly negotiate
with whoever is trading up that is a
very common dynamic even if you don't
want the guy you need to know everything
you can know so because you're trading
the player not the pick and this is
their opportunity to turn the tables on
what happened with rg three eight years
ago and i think at some level they're
fascinated by the opportunity to stick
it to someone else the way the rams
stuck it to them when they moved up they
gave up the sixth overall pick two first
rounders in the second round to make
that move eight years ago this is an
opportunity at revenge not against the
rams but against some other unsuspecting
team that would jump up the number two
here's the other thing let's throw out
there mike because the nfl is a copycat
league teams will not do something if
it's seen out as out of the box if it's
seen like something that's crazy well
guess what happened last year mike the
arizona cardinals traded the first round
pick that they had used the year before
with joss erosion for kyler murray now
obviously having the number one pick
changes things but you now have that
blueprint there and i think the arizona
cardinals are probably pretty happy that
they did they went down that path
instead of saying the stubborn path
where hey we picked this guy we have to
give him three four years and see how it
goes so i think that adds a little
wrinkle to it that we've seen it that if
you if even if you have picked a
franchise quarterback in the first round
if the next year there's a better guy
ready to go and you can tell yourself
this is the guy
you can cut bait and just go for it
because that's the way to win football
games and to put that one final point on
it the argument i made last year about
the cardinals it's better to roll the
dice on the potential transformational
talent and get it wrong than to pass on
him and to be that team that could have
had him and didn't that's the challenge
for washington and to an excellent point
all right before we go let's finish
where we started because we are getting
some feedback about the tom brady
coverage you and i both believe it's
good for business this one comes from
steve i won't use his last name channel
turned to my lottery dream home tired of
listening to the tom brady show you
bleeping
bleep so thank you for that feedback
steve i guess
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports